welcome to the presentation on basic
trigonometry sorry it's taken so long to
get a new video out but i had a lot of
family in town so let's get started with
trigonometry let me get the pen tool all
set up i'm a little rusty i'll use green
trigonometry
i think it means
tree trigonometry
i think it's from ancient greek and it
means triangle
measure i think that i read it on
wikipedia a couple days ago so i believe
that's the case but all that all
trigonometry is is really the study of
right triangles and the relationship
between the sides and the angles of a
right triangle now that might sound a
little confusing but i'll get started
and and actually you've probably seen a
lot of these things that we're going to
go over now and you'll finally know what
those buttons on the calculator actually
do
so let's start with a a right triangle
let's see
so it's a triangle
and a six it's a right triangle
and let's do just for simplicity let's
say that this side is three
this side is four and then the
hypotenuse is five
so the trig functions
tell you that for any angle
it tells you what the ratios of the
sides of the triangle are relative to
that angle let me give you an example
let's call this angle
theta theta is the
the greek alphabet people tend to use
for
the angle that you're going to find a
trig function of
let's say you wanted to find
the
sine
sine
and sin is short for s-i-n-e
let's say you wanted to find the sine of
theta
so before we solve the sine of theta i'm
just going to throw out a mnemonic that
i remembered when i was learning this in
school and i carry it every time and
every time i do a trick
a trig problem i actually write down on
the page where i or at least repeat it
to myself
and this is
so
toa
i have i have vague memories of my math
teacher in high school telling a story
about some indian princess who's named
sokato but i forget but all you have to
remember is sokatoa
now you might say well what is sokatua
well sokatoa says that sine
is opposite over hypotenuse cosine is
adjacent over hypotenuse
and
tangent is opposite over adjacent now
that's going to be confusing right now
but we're going to do a lot of examples
and i think it's going to make sense so
let's go back to this problem we wanted
to know what the sine of theta theta is
this angle in the triangle
so let's go to our mnemonic sohcahtoa so
which one is sine
well s for sine
so we use so and we know that sine from
this mnemonic
sine
sine of let's say theta is equal to
opposite over hypotenuse
opposite
over hypotenuse
okay so let's just figure out what the
opposite and the hypotenuse are
well what is the opposite side of this
angle
excuse me well if we just go opposite
the angle let's go here the opposite
side is 4 is this is this length of 4
i'll make that in a color
oh i thought i was changing colors
yeah so this side is the opposite and
i'll circle it
now which side is a hypotenuse and you
know this one we've been doing this in
the pythagorean theorem modules
the long side or the side opposite the
right angle is the hypotenuse
so that is the hypotenuse
so now i think we're ready to figure out
what the sine of theta is
the sine whoops i stayed in pink sine of
theta is equal to the opposite side
four
over the hypotenuse which is
five
we're done
let's figure out what let me erase part
of
part of this and we'll figure out some
more things about this triangle
let me erase this
i think if you practice this you'll
realize that this is probably one of the
easier things you learn in mathematics
and it's actually shocking that they
take that they they only they wait till
pre-calculus to teach this because
a smart
middle schooler could i think easily
handle this
not not to make you feel bad if you're
not getting it but just to give you
confidence that you will get it and you
will realize that it is very simple
let's go back to okay so let's let's
figure out what the cosine
and cos is short for
cosine i'll write it out cosine but you
can i'm sure you've seen it before
so what is the cosine of theta
well we go back to our new not mnemonic
sohcahtoa well cosine is the ka
right
and that tells us that cosine of theta
is equal to adjacent over hypotenuse
adjacent over hypotenuse
well once again let's figure out what
the adjacent side is
well the adjacent side
this is the 4 the this side was the
opposite side right because it's
opposite
the angle this side is the hypotenuse
because it's the longest side and then
just by deductive reasoning but also
just by looking at it you see that this
side right here the the side of length
three is adjacent to the angle right
adjacent means right beside it
so that's the adjacent side
and we already figured out that the
hypotenuse is that side that i wrote in
pink
so we're ready to figure out what cosine
of theta equals
let me write it in yeah there you go
cosine
of theta
is equal to the adjacent side
that's three
over
the hypotenuse which is this pink side
five
pretty straight forward isn't it
let's do another one
okay i don't want to erase the whole
thing i just want to erase part of the
page because i want to keep using this
triangle
let's see
let's see
let's see
okay one left the toa
so if you if you remember what i said a
little while ago uh well we'll figure it
out but uh
what is that oh look how big that is
what is the tan of theta or the tangent
of theta
well let's go back to our mnemonic
toa right
toe is for tangent or t for tangent so
it tells us that tangent is the opposite
over the adjacent
so tan of theta
is equal to opposite
over adjacent
well that equals well what was the
opposite side
right the opposite side was four
right and what was the adjacent side
well we just saw it as three
so the tangent of this angle is four
over three
now let's do uh another angle on this
let's call this angle
here
let's call this angle here um i don't
know let's call it x um
i don't know any other greek letters
let's call that angle x
so if we wanted to figure out the tan of
x let's see let's see if it's the same
as the tan of theta the tan of x
well now what's the opposite side
well now the opposite side is is the
white side right because opposite this
angle
is the three side
so
we see here tan is opposite over
adjacent so opposite is 3
and then
adjacent is 4 so it's interesting
the tangent of this angle is
the inverse of the tangent of that angle
i don't want to confuse it too much but
i just want to show you that when you
take the trig functions it matters which
angle of the right angle you're taking
the the functions of and you might be
saying well this is all good and well
sal but what what use is this well we'll
later show you that
if you have some of the information so
you know an angle and you know a side or
you know a couple of sides you can
figure out any and if you have either
a slide ruler or a trig table or a good
calculator
you can figure out given the sides of a
triangle you can figure out the angles
or given an angle and a side you could
figure out other sides and we're
actually going to do that in the next
module
so hopefully this gives you a little bit
of introduction i'm almost out of time
on the youtube 10 minute limit so i'm
going to wait to do a couple more
examples in the next video
see you in the next presentation
bye